jason it is your story oh thank you drew
next up i'm hoping for a lively debate
on this one so the blog scary mommy
brought this question to the forefront
recently
does flirting qualify
as cheating now some people say
absolutely not uh while other people say
if it feels like cheating in your gut it
is probably cheating so
drew's news table what say you this is
such a good discussion beyond jenny you
want to kick us off it always feels like
cheating in my gut so
when you're doing even when i'm talking
to my dry cleaner but you know for me
it's like a fine line and by fine i mean
like that line really isn't there i just
like to like
make sure everybody is in love with me
it's like being totally honest i love
jason's the same way right we're kind of
the same way yes i but it's funny i've
definitely
met guys who think that they're like
still engaged to jenny you know
they're engaged
i was never engaged i know that's the j
i'm saying like you definitely
have i think given god's team i have
been known
when i was with jason but i have gone on
accidental dates with people where i
think we're just hanging out and that i
find out that we're on a date
really
i have a good friend on dating and then
it's like extra gate extra day but you
know does this still happen
i haven't gotten any accidental dates
lately but i did have a nanny fall in
love with me so i guess maybe it's
happening still really that's true you
guys are fascinating
i never know what's gonna happen next
we've both been flirting with tiki since
we sat down
you're not wrong
doesn't it have to be a two-way street
like if someone's flirting and the other
person doesn't feel like
they're you're flirting with them is it
actually flirting are you saying you're
not flirting back with us
because i thought for sure you were i
mean you showed up in my dressing room i
thought
i literally came in it was like i'm a
huge fan yeah
i think i said that but i think it was
flirting so was it actually flirting
maybe you thought you were political
everybody kisses on the lips that's how
you show love
what do you think of this i don't think
that flirting is necessarily cheating
but i do think it's dangerous it's like
if you're on a diet and you smell a
muffin right like you're just smelling
the muffin you're not
you're not eating the muffin but you're
going to think about that muffin all day
long
interesting choice of analogy
[Applause]
i definitely i feel like i used to uh
like i used to have open relationships i
used to like flirt i don't know i was so
carefree
and the older i get the less drama i
want the more sensitive i am i don't
want to hurt anybody's feelings i don't
want my feelings hurt
so i am like if it's feeling like taboo
just cut it right there because i just
don't want to hurt anyone's feelings and
i just don't want mine hurt and i'm just
old and tired i'm a golden girl okay
i am over
the drama i really am i think it's good
if it starts to feel wrong it's probably
wrong i just gotta ask a question ross
did you go back and eat the muffin a
week later
how did you ever succumb to the muffin i
have dabbled in muffin yes i have thank
you so much
[Applause]
his and hers on these stories jenny you
are up next okay i'm gonna follow up
jason's debate with another this one has
to do with how we text
best life reports you should never end
your text message with a period experts
say using a period can come off as rude
especially to young people it feels way
too formal and reads like you don't feel
comfortable enough with the person
you're texting with to just relax
do you all end texts with periods is my
question i do yeah i do i feel the exact
opposite about the flirting which is oh
i don't want to hurt people's feelings i
don't want the drama i don't want the
sensitivity this one everyone better get
over it texting is e cummings it's a
field to do whatever you want people
send each other giphies and emojis and
exclamation points and ellipses
you are all being oversensitive i won't
have it really yeah
[Applause]
i
i'm constantly rereading my text like oh
did i have i kind of i got to tell you
i'm kind of with this uh the the not
period thing i definitely find myself or
i'll separate the thoughts
right so instead of putting in like a
long one text i'll do a bump bubble and
then do another thought kind of like a
kind of a run on but it feels a little
less abrupt it feels less i don't know
that's sort of my um like people are
actually hearing what you're typing
yes
when i s when i type people listen
i take it very seriously i i text like
it's going to be graded i'm always the
period in a common punctuation and i i
don't like it when people text like
like seven texts for one thing you know
what i mean like you are very good at
sending a very long text and it gets
very oh drew texts me and i'm reading it
you scroll you keep scrolling
but like if you're busy i i take time
out for drew i like to sit and write her
a little novel but you're right i'm long
and i'm long you are but i like it he
seems like someone who's making your
pocket vibrate 30 times every
[Laughter]
i love this i love this this my happy
place
[Music]